the holiday shopping season is here and
online sales are booming according to
Adobe Analytics online shoppers spent
more than three and a half billion
dollars by 8:00 p.m. on Black Friday
that is an increase of nearly 16 percent
from a year ago while there has been
talk of the death of Black Friday for
years most purchases still happen at
brick-and-mortar stores Adriana Diaz is
at Macy's flagship store here in New
York Adriana good morning good morning
that's right one expert told us that
even though Black Friday sales are
starting earlier and earlier every year
and of course a lot of people are buying
things online he said
Black Friday is still relevant and it
sure was here at Macy's yesterday it was
so busy that the cash registers were
having issues processing the credit
cards and gift cards because of a
system-wide slowdown everywhere it's
pretty much like 50 percent of buy one
get one all those good deals that I
definitely want
I got a fabulous bedding set for almost
50% off it was worth it
wait all year for this I just go buy
things that people are telling me that's
on sale all across the country shoppers
lined up then spilled into stores for
deep discounts while some retailers
started rolling out the deal thus far
back is October tradition brought
Suzanne Brant out to the mall on Black
Friday for how many years 25 years three
sisters-in-law have been getting
together on Black Friday it's a sacred
day we get together we do all our
shopping more than 164 million people
are expected to open their wallets this
holiday weekend up from about 154
million last year wagers are ticking up
a little bit and so they want to get out
and spend and have a good time this
holiday season when all is said and done
consumers will have spent about 1.4
trillion dollars this holiday season
says USA Today business correspondent
serese Jones the holiday season from
Black Friday to New Year's Eve is
critical a lot of retailers make half of
their revenue for the year within that
period of time and it's even more
critical now because you know Amazon is
really ascendant right I mean there's
scooping up all the sales and all the
money Toys R Us chief merchandising
officer Richard Berry says that's why
his stores are providing unique in-store
experiences for this year we launched
our fan vault so this is an area where
we're bringing collective collectible
products yes kids level those products
but guess what adults love them much
more and of course there's also those
cute unique items that maybe you
wouldn't admit that you want but
secretly you do
so now that Black Friday is behind us we
are of course looking forward to Cyber
Monday Target and Walmart will have
thousands of discounts online and Amazon
is expected to offer up to 50% off some
gadgets shoppers are expected to spend
6.6 billion dollars on Monday Alex
oMG retail is changing Adriana Diaz here
in New York begs adrionna